so you're like talking to your friends
or coworkers and you notice the strange
pattern this happened like five minutes
ago we've been friends for like like 11
years and then I was like hello and I
was like please can I have my ticket
I'm always weird about like well like
they wanted to watch it together and I
was like well I don't want to sit there
with them like it or hate it you can
actually hear the word like everywhere
from celebrities but like if they ask
about your lips like own up to it to
movies but people came that like did not
RSVP so I was like totally buggin and
yes our own mouths I say like all the
time
and most of the time no I do not notice
that I'm saying like unless it's like oh
now I do so where exactly did this
annoying trend begin
and more importantly why believe it or
not the way we use like can be traced
back as far as the late 19th century
right here on the pages from the 1886
Scottish novel kidnapped by Robert Louis
Stevenson but it wasn't until the 1950s
that a certain group brought the word to
spotlight it's a Beat Generation the
young rebellious Beat Generation soon
picked up the interjection as a sign of
cool and it was used so frequently that
it turned into a trope for any beatnik
characters in pop culture like how
should I know jazz like he never tells
me not what's that on your chin can't
you tell man it's like a beard the beats
played an important role in introducing
the new use of like to a larger audience
especially the younger generations and
20 years later when the word rose to
prominence once again it wasn't from the
rebellious beat writers and bars but
from the young girls in the malls of San
Fernando Valley and they had a name for
themselves their high school girls for
the lingo style of dress and philosophy
all the room
they are valley girl the valley girl was
a socio-economic stereotype referring to
the young upper-class white girls living
in the San Fernando Valley
these girls were known for spending days
at the mall and dressing head-to-toe in
pink but what stood out the most was the
way they spoke and think of the muscles
straining and the job being like pulled
out make it seem as if it's rolling off
your tongue let's try out I am sure he
even had its own name Valley speak it
was what linguists call a socio light a
set of dialect slang and words used by a
specific class of people it includes
words and phrases like tubular totally
grody gag me with a spoon
some of which are still used today and
of course the word like but it was still
just a regional phenomenon until a
single record changed all of that
in 1982 musician Frank Zappa and his
daughter moon Zappa released their
single Valley Girl a novelty song
written to mock and satirize the valley
girl culture to their surprise the song
was a massive hit peaking at number 32
on the Billboard chart and was even
nominated for a Grammy the song that was
meant to be a parody had ironically
turned valley girls and valley speak
into a national phenomenon I've been
doing this for almost 20 years and this
is the most successful record that has
ever occurred and the only reason it's
accessible is because it's an accident
the valley girls had turned from a
stereotype that symbolized Southern
California's shallow materialism into a
cool idolized
icon and the Californian entertainment
industry only fueled its spread this
time in movies and TV shows a year after
the song's release films like Fast Times
at Ridgemont High and valley girl were
made to quickly take advantage of the
trend which then led to other movies and
shows like clueless Mean Girls and
Beverly Hills 90210 all targeting a
younger demographic
although pop culture has contributed to
the words widespread popularity
linguists have come to believe that it
might also be because of how we use the
word yeah everyone says like it's just
the way people like talk the word
originally began with just two
definitions the verb in the old english
leaky and meaning to feel attracted
towards and the adjective from the old
english like meaning similar to but over
time it's not developed one but four
more definitions each serving an
entirely different purpose like the
quote ativ used to quote our own or
someone else's words she would just say
hey do you have pay pal and I was like I
don't have pay pal I am venmo a filler I
mainly used for pause and flow it was
really just amazing like I kept thinking
about it afterwards in adverb also known
as
that's used for approximation this
happened like five minutes ago and
what's known as a discourse particle to
emphasize a point she has this bananas
phobia of blood like it's she's
completely like debilitated and that's
not all recent studies have suggested
that the word might also have a social
function acting as a cue to seem
informal and friendly another reason why
it's so prevalent among young girls over
the years the way we used like has been
used as a prime example of how younger
generations are destroying the English
language the internet is full of advice
on how to stop saying the word
and schools have gone as far as to ban
their students from saying it what
chances are they won't work if history
has proven one thing language evolves
and spreads no matter what we want so as
long as we continue to speak how we say
like is like not going anywhere
I did think of that because I was like
do I think I'm saying like a little bit
too often but no I was being framed